ladies and gentlemen rishi sooner
hi hi
brilliant
so we're going to do exactly the same as
we did with lift cross is that okay
we're going to start with the questions
from the audience and then i've got some
questions for you as well if that's okay
here we go let's start our first
question uh with matthew
matthew from kent there he is in the
middle there matthew thank you
is there a point that you would stand
aside in this campaign mr sunak give
given opinion polls are pointing to a
dominant mistrust win
and also we're seeing daily declarations
from big tory big guns uh in her favor
well thanks for the question matthew and
the quick answer is no and that's
because well thank you
and you know what that's that's because
i'm fighting for something i really
believe in and i'm taking my ideas
around the country i'm talking to all of
you our members across the country about
what i think is best for our country at
a really difficult time and i want to
have that debate with people because i
passionately believe what i'm saying is
right i want to convince as many people
of that as possible and hopefully i can
do that with you all tonight but you
talk about big guns i mean i've also had
in the mp phase of this in parliament
the most number of mps support me not
just in the first round but in every
round since you talk about big guns
coming out i just had nigel lawson this
morning margaret thatcher's chancellor
supporting my approach to the economy
michael howard a former leader of our
party just introduced me at a hustings
yesterday william hague another leader
of our party my predecessor in richmond
and north yorkshire all supporting my
candidacy so look i think i've got lots
of support but i'm gonna fight
incredibly hard till the last day of
this campaign for each and every one of
your votes the stakes are really high
i'm passionate what i believe in and i
want to try and convince you all that
i'm right anybody else that's going to
support mr sooner
i'll get a few you're all very quiet
though so you've got a question uh yes
hi um now i've been a tory for the last
30 years and i did stand for parliament
in 2005. now i've been absolutely
disgusted with the uh level of disunity
within the tory party so yes i'll be
supporting you uh but once you if you do
become prime minister how will you
ensure that you unite the tory party so
that we can win the next general
election yeah no i'm so glad you are so
it's a really important point because i
think i think how we select this
audience we're on the same team right
we're all part of the same conservative
family and we are going to need to come
back together afterwards and look i
think you can take some comfort from the
fact that not only do i have the most
support of mps in parliament that
support is drawn from every bit of our
parliamentary party people in the north
mps in the south mps who voted remain
mps who voted leave experienced
colleagues the likes of which we just
talked about matthew's question but
brand new mps as well mps in rural areas
and urban areas so that's the breadth of
my support because that's the kind of
person i am that i could i can build a
broad team around me and that's what i'm
going to do in government i want to make
sure that we have a government that
represents all the talents and
traditions of our amazing party and you
saw some of that on display in this
leadership election early on i want all
of you to be able to look up the
government and feel a piece of your view
of conservatism represented that's how
we're going to bring people back
together because we all know in this
room the enemy is not me or liz or
anyone else our real opposition is
kirstama in the labour party and i'm the
person who can take the fight to them
and win the next election for all of us
because that's what we all want to see
isn't it
um
actually that's a similar question to
andrew from west london where's andrew
andrew i'm over here you're over there
as well andrew were you happy with that
response
well
sort of but yeah i think
i think historically we have to look at
the fact that parties that are divided
do not win elections we are two years
out less than two years out from a
general election
what specifics can we do what specifics
can you do
to reunite the party
well well andrew you're right we are
only a couple years out from a general
election and that's why getting on with
the job as quickly as possible is really
important we don't have time to waste so
it starts day one with building that
team that i talked about that does bring
people back together around the cabinet
table and across government no more
factions no more who supported who in
the leadership contest we have to put
all that aside the moment this contests
end and start looking forward and start
delivering for the british people we've
got real challenges and i'm sure we're
going to get to talk about the economy
in a minute but that's the number one
challenge we've got to get the nhs
backlogs down we've got to get to grips
with illegal migration we've got to make
sure that we provide more energy for us
all at home there's lots of challenges
we've got and we need to get on and do
them fast so if we've got a brand new
team united in purpose to deliver for
the british people and focus on the
prize of winning the next election i
think that will galvanize minds i'm the
person that can bring people together
and lead us to that victory okay can i
come back very quickly if you wouldn't
mind so so how many people in the
current cabinet would you have in your
cabinet okay
well andrew i wouldn't i don't think
you'd expect me to answer that a it's
premature as we heard from the first
question i've got a lot of work to do in
this campaign and i'm going to fight for
every vote and that's what i'm focused
on right now but i will tell you i will
build a team that reflects the talents
and traditions of our entire party okay
the ones that's what
okay and see yourself and everyone else
reflecting okay claire from solid hall
claire okay hi there hi hi
so the my question is
hi uh the security of this country
worries me greatly with all the sober
rattling from russia china iran and
north korea
so if you become pm will you commit to
increasing the size and budget of our
armed forces to make this country once
again a force to be reckoned with
yes claire that the simple answer is
absolutely and i don't want to say once
again because i think we are already a
force to be reckoned with an amazing
country that projects our values and our
influence around the world supporting
our allies so i don't think we have to
think that we're not we already are but
it's always more we can do now remember
i was the chancellor who oversaw the
largest increase in the defense budget
since the end of the cold war that's my
track record and actually i singled out
the ministry of defense in the middle of
the pandemic for a special treatment
because they were going through a period
where they were looking at future
threats they needed the certainty of
knowing that they had the funding to
make all those investments and the new
technologies that would keep us safe
that's why i gave him the special
treatment that's not what the prime
minister said he said that you had to be
actually ben wallace said the prime
minister had to overrule you uh no
that's not right we actually do all this
so
i'm not gonna talk of any of my
colleagues but ultimately i'm the
chancellor that's responsible for the
decisions on how we spend our money and
that's what i did right but you don't
have to take my my word for it there
when it came to ukraine what else did we
do i managed to find 2 billion pounds
from a cross government to send to
ukraine to support them so we can help
them and protect our values and stand up
to russian aggression but what i'm not
going to do is stand here and give you
an arbitrary target and i i know that's
what liz has said in this campaign and i
don't believe in that i don't think
that's the right response to defense
spending i don't believe in arbitrary
targets i believe in taking a threat
based approach i believe in looking at
the threats we face and then allocating
spending accordingly so i can commit to
you claire is this i will tell you i
will invest whatever it takes to keep
you and everyone else in our country
safe because that is the first duty of a
prime minister and it's certainly the
first duty of a conservative prime
minister follow up from this lady here
just wait for the microphone madam if
you would there we go thank you you were
also the chancellor that introduced eat
out to dine out
at a cost of 850 million pounds and
according to the university of warwick
that was responsible for an increase of
nuclear cases of between eight and 17
percent
well actually that's one study that said
that and i don't think it's right
and it doesn't explain the fact that in
almost any every other country around
europe everyone else experienced another
wave of covid and they didn't all have
the same policy so it's a bit odd to
blame that policy for an increase in
covert cases when that happened across
europe and indeed across most of the
world but i'll tell you what i was
thinking at that moment what i was
looking at was a situation where we had
hundreds of thousands of largely small
hospitality businesses that were on the
brink of bankruptcy because in this
country everyone was so scared and all
the evidence said that no one was going
to go back out again and in an economy
like ours that would have been
disastrous and you know what's worse two
million people work in all those small
businesses and those two million people
are disproportionately young
they're women they're working part-time
they're people who are coming off
unemployment benefit into work so as a
matter of social justice i wanted to
protect those jobs those families
livelihoods that's why i did it and
everywhere i go in this campaign across
the country i have people who come up to
me and say thank you for that because it
saved our business and it saved those
jobs tom
[Applause]
tom from berry sent edmonds i'm right
behind you okay there we go i'm all
behind everything
that sounded funny i'm so sorry i'm a
town councillor for various edmonds oh
brilliant thank you and we lost our
kings road nhs dentist they were
brilliant that was in 2018. now some of
us are going around talking like tube
stations mind the gap mind the gap what
can be done it's 2022
we need nhs dentistry because frankly a
lot of us cannot afford to go private
and we have fantastic private dentists
precedence but we need our nhs back what
can you do how soon can you do it that's
the problem i'm running out of teeth
what happened
and that's because i drank an enormous
amount of coke when i was a youngster so
i know i feel your pain and we do need
good dentistry and look the nhs first of
all is everyone's number one public
service priority and i grew up in an nhs
household you may have heard on this
campaign my dad he never mentions it
just checking you never know right you
know and my mom ran a chemist where i
grew up so i spent my time working in
that i understand how important
especially primary care is but look you
know if we're going to get to grips with
this and make sure that there is money
for nhs dentistry we just have to be
bolder about reforming the nhs to get
more efficiency out of it now i'm
someone who you can absolutely trust
with the nhs i'm someone who did
something quite difficult and that's
create a new funding stream to support
not just the nhs but social care because
it does start with putting more
resources in to help recover from the
pandemic was an easy thing for me to do
lots of people are upset with me about
it but i believe it was the right thing
for the country the right thing to
support our fantastic nhs doctors and
nurses but money money's not enough we
need to reform things so we can get more
efficiency and invest in things like
dentistry i'll give you one example of
something that i'm prepared to do which
is a bit bold it is a bit radical and
not everyone will love it but i want to
show you that i'm going to bring some
change and that's tackling missed
appointments now we have over 10 million
missed appointments every year and it's
not just gps it's in hospitals at the
same time we've got lots of people
sitting there anxiously waiting for
treatment and i've said that's not
acceptable so we need to be tougher on
missed appointments because if we are
then if people can cancel them in
advance properly we free up all that
extra capacity and none of us have had
to pay an extra penny in taxes to do
that how is that workable though thank
you
how's that workable what about people
who can't afford to pay the 10 pounds
and they miss the so they can't pay to
afford to pay their fine um do they not
get treatment in future what happens
well actually okay as i said it you
don't have to do a people's first myst
it can be for people who missed a second
appointment because there are just so
many that there's a lot of space in the
system and i do think it's right to
actually say hang on we believe in an
nhs that's free at the point of use but
it's not free at the point of misuse and
when people don't show up for
appointments they are depriving other
people of treatment that they need so
there's someone equally vulnerable
waiting there sitting on a waiting list
waiting to see their consultant or their
gp and they're not getting that chance
because someone else has just not
bothered to show up and that's not all
right and look there will be some people
like you who say oh gosh maybe we
shouldn't do that but if we're not
prepared to be hanging it's the lancet
saying if we're not prepared to do
something
that miss their appointments for all
sorts of reasons and they can you can be
compassionate first time but at the end
of the day if we all want to cut taxes
in this country if we want to find money
to spend more on dentistry we have to be
prepared to do things differently
challenge the system and that's what i'm
prepared to do because i want to have
great healthcare i want to have great
dentistry for you and for my future
feelings but i do want to be able to cut
your taxes too we're only going to be
able to do that if we're going to reform
things and do things differently that's
the kind of prime minister i'm going to
be
you can only be compassionate once um
jeff from devon jeff where are we jeff
hi hey jeff oh you're all over here
today hi is it jeff what's up yes trisha
yes sir hi hi um given the problems
we've had with borders control and
obviously the massive controversy with
the rwanda policy what's your plan to
um cut illegal channel crossings yes
great question and something i've been
talking a lot about over the last couple
of weeks look you know i'm the product
of this country's
extraordinarily compassionate approach
to welcoming immigrants to our shores my
family are beneficiary of that probably
others in the audience and it's
something that we should all feel really
proud of it's something that britain is
amazing at and even most recently
ukraine hong kong syria afghanistan we
showed our compassion but it is also
absolutely right that we have control
over our borders because all the people
i just mentioned came here legally and
what is not right is for people to break
the rules and come here illegally the
scenes we see on our tv screens and
small boat crossings are wrong and they
need to stop and i'm prepared again to
do some different things to be bold and
radical to stop them there's a ten point
plan on my website with a video so you
please go and have a look at that
tonight and anyone else that's
interested in this topic i'll give you
two examples of things i'm prepared to
do now one is we need to change the
definition of asylum and move away from
this european definition which has
become very broad it's exploited by
lefty lawyers and means it's very hard
to remove people i suggest moving to a
different definition another legal
standard internationally used by i think
the australians and others and that is a
much tighter definition and will allow
us to reject more people so that's one
thing we can do the second thing is
we've got to get smarter about our
foreign policy at the moment we'll
happily talk to a country and talk about
the trade deal we're going to give them
and maybe even the aid that we're going
to send that country but we don't then
also say hang on you have to take back
your failed asylum seekers well that's
not right we should be more joined up we
should be tougher about that so that's
just two other things in my ten point
plan but fundamentally we must get a
grip of this we have to make the rwanda
policy work i will do whatever it takes
including legal changes if required to
make it work so we get control of our
borders although we're a compassionate
country and will always be it's entirely
right and many of us vote to brexit for
this reason that we are in control of
who's coming here that's a simple thing
and i will deliver it as pm okay
applause on that one gentleman there
really quickly because we need to move
on if we can just stretch over with the
microphone for you sir there we go your
question really quickly so we currently
have a point-based immigration system do
you propose any changes or are you happy
to keep it as is this
so look on on immigration look for we
have to tackle this question of illegal
jeff's question on illegal migration we
shall tackle that robustly and radically
so that's part one now with the rest of
immigration right there's a couple of
things i i want to be pragmatic about
this so i want to make sure that we're
also supporting our economy to grow
and that means having an immigration
system that actually welcomes the best
and the brightest from around the world
because if we want to grow our economy
if we want people here who are going to
set up companies of the future who are
going to come and research in our
universities who are going to come and
work at some of our fastest growing
companies actually we want to have a
visa regime that makes with us the best
place in the world for all those people
to come i started reforming the system
as chancellor and as prime minister i
want to finish the job so that the best
and the brightest wherever they are
around the world america india brazil
wherever they think huh the uk is the
place i want to come because if we can
attract them here it's going to be good
for all of us it's going to be good for
the economy and that's something that i
want to deliver okay we've got a
question from alexander on trust
alexander you've got a question hi
alexander hi alexander yeah good to see
you buddy uh what does honesty mean to
you in politics and
leadership
great question
honestly in a sense it means telling you
the truth right and even when that's not
easy and i think you can see in this
leadership election
that's what i'm doing right and that
first question at the beginning of how
i'm doing in the polls and all of that
right i am saying some things that are
maybe not the easiest thing in the world
to hear i'm not sitting here or standing
here promising you tens and tens of
billions of pounds of goodies straight
away because i don't think that's the
right thing to do for our economy i
think it's risky i think it risks making
the inflation problem far worse and
costing you all far more and you know
what my life would be far easier if i
wasn't saying that right but i want to
be honest with you i want to be straight
with a country about the challenges we
face and what is going to be required to
fix them and that's why i think you can
trust me on this because i'm prepared to
do that even though it's going to cost
me politically
at two mr sunak though
at two mr sunak we we've seen the images
of what you were allegedly uh the the uh
nadine doris i think it was who came up
with this i don't know has anybody seen
it
stan stabbing you in the back i mean how
do you respond to that
sorry kate what are you well my point is
we're talking about trust you can't be
trusted
uh what what which means
you unite in boris for your own interest
that's there you go
right perfect right okay let's let's
address that actually great that you've
raised it so what was your name sir
stephen right so yes i worked with the
prime minister for a couple of years and
i'm really proud of the work we achieved
together actually and i think he
deserves enormous credit for what he
achieved during that time and i as i
said i'm proud to have been a part of it
and he gave me the job i had and i'm
grateful to him for it but it got to a
point where
it was too difficult for me to stay now
we had well documented differences of
opinion on economic policy as you can
see in this leadership campaign by the
way and it's simply impossible for a
chancellor and prime minister
not to be on the same page when it comes
to economic policy that doesn't make
sense and and there's no way that can
work so of course i had no choice but to
go but also
it came to a point where the government
was on the wrong side of an ethical
problem that i could not defend and
enough was enough for me but it wasn't
just me steve it was 60 other members of
parliament all left the government
at the same time because for them enough
was enough okay and that's why we're
here because we need to change things in
december last year did they rishi you
you've been campaigning for a long time
and it was perfectly timed a cynical
motivation to try and get you into
number 10. no that's just
simply not true so i was due to give a
speech with the prime minister the next
week and in the conversations about
putting that speech together on the
economy it was clear our differences
were too big to reconcile okay so that
was the reason plus i think let's not
not look at the hit the boss with rose
tinted spectacles here everyone
remembers what was going on with chris
pincher right
that was a serious ethical question that
the government was on the wrong side of
again and i couldn't defend it maybe
you're okay to defend that i wasn't okay
to defend it 60 other members of the
government were not okay to defend it
because it was wrong and that's why
we're here because we need to change
things we need to bring trust and
integrity and decency and honesty back
into politics and that's what i want to
do as prime minister okay okay i'm going
to have to brush up on my shakespearean
references i can tell
um let's bring in david from london
finally where are you david david's here
hi davey gone hi kay thank you david hi
good evening mr seanak um how will you
balance the need to address the
escalating cost of living crisis
particularly for those that are on lower
incomes
alongside the need to keep the economy
in good order and national debt not
spiraling out of control
david you know your question
is actually the most important one
facing the country right now right and
i'm sure many of you saw what the bank
and the bank of england had to say today
and if we in the conservative party need
to get real and fast because the lights
on the economy are flashing red and the
root cause is inflation now i'm worried
that liz truss's plans will make the
situation worse and what i want to do is
different i think the government's
number one priority should be grappling
with inflation that's what i want to do
i also want to help people with the cost
of living over the autumn and winter
particularly as you said the people who
most need our help and that's what i
announced as chancellor that's how i
acted over the past two years that's
what i'll do as your prime minister
that's what a conservative government
should do support those who need our
help most at a time of need but then
also
i want to grow the economy and i want
businesses to be producing more and
that's how we're going to not just grow
the economy and create jobs is how we're
going to get inflation down over time
i've got a plan to do all of those
things but it all starts with not making
the situation worse because if we just
put fuel on the fire of this inflation
spiral all of us all of you are going to
just end up with higher mortgage rates
savings and pensions that are eaten away
and misery for millions i don't want
that to happen and that's why i am so
focused on gripping inflation first okay
ladies and gentlemen mr sunak